[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a la entrevista en
france 24
el pasado lunes 14 de marzo durante el
noticiero de perevi canal el principal
canal estatal ruso una mujer irrumpió en
la emisión y mostró un cartel
oponiéndose a la guerra en ucrania esa
mujer es marina oceánico va y es nuestra
invitada de hoy desde moscú muchas
gracias por estar con nosotros
y
muchas gracias por su invitación
en primer lugar quiero agradecerle al
presidente macrón por su increíble
propuesta me propuso que me mudara a
francia y me ofreció el asilo político
pero desgraciadamente no podría aceptar
esta oferta porque soy una patriota
quiero quedarme a vivir en mi país con
mi familia
todos mis amigos están aquí y quiero
quedarme en rúsia
[Música]
por eso la multaron con 30.000 rublos
unos 275 dólares fue declarada culpable
de cometer una infracción administrativa
no tanto por lo que hizo durante la
instrucción en el noticiero sino también
por un vídeo que publicó en las redes
sociales en el que él iniciaba la guerra
de ucrania como un crimen a rusia como
el agresor y a vladimir putin como el
responsable llamaba a los rusos a
manifestarse hoy quedó en libertad pero
teme que se les siga persiguiendo
especialmente por la vía penal
y ciertamente se me impuso una multa
como sanción administrativa por este
vídeo que hizo circular en el que
explicaba mi acción el vídeo se calificó
como una llamada a salir a la calle a
manifestarse a protestar y efectivamente
esta historia no termina con esta multa
porque todavía no me han sancionado por
esta interrupción durante el noticiero
por lo que creo que seré objeto de otras
sanciones
avn a estas sanciones pueden ser graves
marc y no sabemos qué publicar lo que
las autoridades rusas llaman información
falsa entre comillas es un delito
castigado con una pena máxima de 15 años
de prisión es esto lo que usted teme
si eso es lo que temo
porque esta persecución penal es muy
real
me enfrento a 15 años de prisión y
espero evitarlo
entonces por qué lo hizo
conocía las consecuencias quizá no
esperaba tener tanto impacto en todo el
planeta pero por qué hacerlo fue algo
sobre lo que reflexionó fue una acción
espontánea fue una acción difícil porque
trabajaba en un medio de comunicación
que es lo contrario de lo que ustedes
personas
creo que en mí el descontento se ha ido
acumulando a lo largo de los años
el descontento por la propaganda justo
al principio las elecciones de
gobernadores fueron canceladas
luego del 2014 sucedió lo de las
repúblicas lnr y de nr
luego el envenenamiento de naval ni
y
su encarcelamiento
y la gota que colmó el vaso el punto de
no retorno fue esta invasión de soldados
rusos en ucrania
un ruso de a pie no puede encontrar una
explicación
como pudimos enviar nuestras fuerzas
armadas a otro estado
ninguno de mis amigos ninguno de mis
conocidos creía en este escenario y ni
siquiera pensaba que fuera posible
creo que hay que ponerle fin a esto
cuanto antes
[Música]
pero usted hizo parte de este canal que
difunde la información que el kremlin
quiere que sea difundida
muy realmente un detonante porque se
podría decir que usted hace todo esto
por años porque de repente ya no podía
aceptarlo
y
eso es lo que estoy diciendo fue la
guerra de ucrania
fue esta guerra la que se convirtió en
el punto de no retorno y en el detonante
y la gente ni siquiera creía que fuera a
suceder que fuera posible
el 24 de febrero perdí el sueño perdí
absolutamente toda la dirección de mi
vida
no podía comer y me di cuenta de que no
podía callar
me enteré de esta nueva ley que permitía
procesar a todas las personas que
salieran a la calle
inmediatamente decidí unirme a estas
acciones de protesta
y
seguir los acontecimientos en las plazas
de moscú
y
enseguida comprendí que estas acciones
no podían ser efectivas porque estaban
muy restringidas muy controladas
así que decidí realizar esta acción y
enviar un fuerte mensaje
de que los rusos
están en contra de la guerra
y decir que no debemos confiar en la
propaganda ni escuchar lo que se dice en
la televisión y que debemos hacer esta
distinción
entre la mentira y la verdad
vladimir putin denunció el miércoles
visitó a los traidores nacionales habló
de una auto purificación necesaria de la
sociedad rusa dijo visitó toda la gente
especialmente el pueblo ruso es capaz de
distinguir a los verdaderos patriotas de
la escoria y los traidores y de
escupirlos como un mosquito que
accidentalmente se le metió en la boca
le asusta oír a vladimir putin decir eso
después de lo que usted hizo
tengo miedo por supuesto
no creo ser parte de la escoria los
rusos que tienen una posición cívica y
no se callan no son escoria
de hecho las personas que salen a la
calle a protestar
no son traidores de su país
son ciudadanos con una posición
ciudadana
pasito
ha recibido alguna amenaza o
intimidación desde su intrusión en el
estudio del canal
y
públicamente nadie me amenazaba pero tal
vez hay algunos comentarios publicados
en internet
no tengo tiempo para leerlos
y ahora trato de alejarme y protegerme
de eso
pero creo que seguramente habrá
comentarios
saben
la sociedad rusa está dividida una parte
o tal vez la mitad está en contra de la
guerra
y la otra mitad apoya al presidente
putin y quiere continuar esta operación
va a renunciar a su puesto en el canal
de televisión
si hoy fui a las oficinas de ostánkino
entregué todos los documentos para mi
despido por decisión mía pero este es un
procedimiento legal
otros rostros conocidos de la televisión
rusa se han distanciado o se fueron de
vacaciones
nos referimos en particular a jana de la
cova
y otra de las estrellas de su canal iván
urgant
para usted es esta una forma de
manifestarse que quizá es menos visible
que la suya o schmied
y por supuesto que la gente tiene miedo
no hay mucha gente capaz de realizar una
acción así
especialmente en estos tiempos
pero últimamente estamos viendo una
tendencia positiva
también en los canales de televisión
[Música]
sé que varios colegas han escrito cartas
han entregado a sus cartas de renuncia
esto nos alegra mucho
pero bueno como bien se sabe
ahora la situación económica es muy
complicada en rusia
por lo que poca gente puede permitirse
el lujo de quedarse desempleada
porque tienen mensualidades que pagar
como pagar sus casas y la renta
los medios de comunicación extranjeros
están cerrados
con lo que los periodistas profesionales
no pueden trabajar ahora
salvan los canales estatales
muy rápidamente para terminar tiene dos
hijos están orgullosos de su mamá
es muy complicado decirlo en primer
lugar están muy asustados tienen miedo
especialmente mi hijo que ya es mayor y
piensa que con este gesto arruiné la
vida de nuestra familia
unidos
pero le expliqué en la vida hay que
reaccionar y tomar decisiones
complicadas
sobre todo para acabar con esta guerra
fraticida
de la serna y baile
sobre todo para detener esta locura
antes de convertirla en una guerra
nuclear
entonces cuando mi hijo sea un poco más
grande
creo que podrá entender lo que hice
[Música]
marina oceánico one muchas gracias por
aceptar responder a las preguntas de
france 24 desde moscú gracias por ver
esta entrevista en nuestro canal sigan
con nosotros para más noticias
[Música]